25 years ago you played a concert in
front of the entire
world
[Music]
one month ago you played in barcelo
california for 40 people most of whom
were there for two dollar taco night
and ted what have you got to say for
yourselves
be excellent to each other and party on
dudes 80s nostalgia is enjoying a
resurgence in these chaotic times no
more so than in hollywood
where shows like the updated karate kid
spin-off cobra kai on netflix
helps us wax on and wax off about a
simpler time
and as we just saw the best dude bro duo
of the decade
reunite in bill and ted face the music
to dispel our cynicism
the big difference of course these many
decades later
ahem is that the protagonists in these
projects are now fathers
middle-aged men confronting the reality
that life rarely turns out the way you
imagined it would
when you were a teenager the sequel also
reminded us that we hadn't seen actor
alex winter who plays bill
in quite some time he had left acting
for documentary filmmaking years ago
most recently making showbiz kids for
hbo about
the child actors like him who sacrificed
childhood for an early start in
hollywood and some of the costs
associated with that more on that in a
moment his documentary on the late
musician frank zappa is set to premiere
next month
and i'm excited to say alex winter joins
us now
alex good evening hi maddie how are you
i'm good it feels like i've been waiting
decades to talk to you because you you
and kyoto
are such a big part of my youth and my
childhood
let me kick off with this question why
did you reunite
it's great to have you why did you
reunite with keanu reeves
to do another bill and ted movie after
all these decades
well we didn't really expect to do that
we've been friends a very long time and
i'm
friend very close friends with chris
mathis and the ned solomon who wrote the
previous two and one night over dinner
they pitched us this idea
and i think that the reason keanu and i
really responded to it was it allowed us
to be
these guys at our age you know it
allowed us to lean into
the life experience of all that had come
in between the last time you saw
us and we just thought it would be very
funny but also very heartwarming to play
these guys
that way actually as grownups
and in bill and ted 3 bill and ted have
to write the song that saves
civilization no pressure there
how do you think they do at solving the
covert crisis better than the current
administration
i don't think that would be terribly
difficult but uh i'd like to think we
could sort it out
yeah i'd like to think that too we were
just speaking to olivia troy former
trump staff are talking about how bad
that's been and we've all been stuck
with that crisis this has been a year of
crisis
there have been many scandals uh in
recent years there's been more news that
i can cope with one of the big
stories of the recent years uh is the
metoo campaign and the metoo hashtag
that went viral i think three years ago
tomorrow
you've spoken um about how the movement
gave you courage to speak out about the
abuse you experienced as a young
performer in hollywood
i think when you were just 12 years old
what would you like
a young performer in crisis right now to
know to
what would you like to share with them
from what you experienced and what
should we
what should we all know about how
prevalent that abuse still is today in
america
well the metoo movement was started by
tarana burke in alabama actually all the
way back in 2006 and it really gained
popularity after the weinstein
revelations of 2017
and a hashtag and social media was much
farther along
uh and then it got picked up it was
really started for
uh girls of color primarily uh who had
experienced sexual assault
and after the weinstein uh news it began
to expand out into other people who had
experienced sexual abuse and other forms
of assault
very gratefully that included child
abuse and sexual child abuse which has
really
been up to now completely taboo and
almost impossible to speak about
publicly
uh male or female and especially males
just given the way our culture functions
so
it was a really helpful and important
thing for me personally i had done all
the work
on myself many many years ago but i had
never been able to speak publicly i've
been dealing with outreach groups and
other private organizations and this
really gave me the ability to go much
more public
and i think that's that's a huge part
towards uh beginning to
stem some of these crisis is the ability
to speak so you asked me what i would
say
yeah i'd say in this climate unlike the
climate in which i came up
um it's actually much safer to speak um
i really didn't feel at 12 13
like i could talk to anyone i didn't
really feel safe talking to anyone until
my mid-30s
and i certainly didn't go public with it
until after the me too
uh i think that movement gave us all
room to feel quite
comfortable under one big umbrella but i
think for kids
now um who often go silent it's a much
safer culture in which to come out and
and speak to someone even if it's
someone within your your sphere and not
feel like you can't be heard and that's
it's really i honestly never thought i
would see that day in my lifetime so it
is a very big
change in the way the culture is working
around these issues
well alex i'm so sorry you had to go
through that and i'm i'm in awe that
you've managed to use that experience to
do so much good in terms
of this campaign and speaking out as you
do we mentioned your documentary showbiz
kids and that you stepped away from the
spotlight to make documentaries like
that
knowing everything you know and
everything you've experienced would you
let
your own kids join the entertainment
industry today if they asked you
you know the film that i made i didn't
want it to be a
black and white because the experiences
aren't black and white i was on broadway
at 12 13
co-starring in a big broadway show with
joel brenner and constance tower and it
was
magic it was a dream come true and i was
in heaven i went on to do peter pan with
sandy duncan for years just
lovely experiences that i wouldn't i
wouldn't exchange for anything
but the lows are quite low and they do
impact you and they do
have consequences not only for you but
for your family
um i have three kids uh they're in the
arts to some degree some aren't
but i have not been faced with this
dilemma the way my mother was
my mother wasn't a stage mom so i was
all singing all dancing by five
i mean i was not gonna stop so
she had to face you know that that
decision does does she let me continue
or not
someone like mara wilson cameron boyce
who is very sadly passed on we're just
born to be
doing this evan rachel um todd bridges
and yet um thankfully i have not uh
had to face this dilemma myself with my
own kids i honestly
not to beat around the bush i don't
think i would honestly i think that if
my kids came to me and asked me if they
could enter the business
i really don't um it's probably largely
to do with my own experiences but i
would probably say to them
wait until you're 18. if i had a kid
like cameron or martin like
almost like myself who's just clearly
born to do that
then i would actually roll up my sleeves
and jump in but it would be a big
commitment
fair enough so let me talk about
uh keanu reeves and yourself who made
your name in this in this movie
so many years ago you remained friends
all these years even though your careers
took kind of
different journeys different paths
different directions i have to ask the
question do you ever regret the fact
that you're not john wick
yes i think i would have made a i think
i'm clearly
much better suited to play john wick and
i think that that'll will probably get
sorted out
maybe john wick four he finds his
long-lost partner
uh alex winter there let's just talk
seriously before we run out of time
elections coming up soon you had a tweet
go viral this week about amy coney
barrett calling her out
you're often very critical about trump
on twitter it's where you and i
discovered each other
have you always been this political or
has the current moment just
radicalized you alex no i came up in a
very politically active family i had
a lot of close family members who were
journalists um
i was you know protesting spiro agnew as
a child
uh i was you know handing out mcgovern
flyers door to door
so this is in my blood and uh i find
twitter very useful actually i think
that it's a you know like anything else
with the internet can be used very
poorly
um it can be used for propaganda but it
can also use be used to join people
together
and to get word out and to help with
voting and voting rights and to now
you know the work that we're doing in
swing states try to get the vote out
i voted absentee i voted uh over a week
ago but
there's stuff that i can do every single
day to try to help make sure we correct
the current climate that we're in
and uh get back on track as a country
hopefully
here's a question you're a dual citizen
of the united states in the uk as i am
now
um if the election goes the way you
don't want it to go do you think you'll
be heading for some kind of escape zone
people with dual nationalities often
envied by other americans because
they've got somewhere to escape to
apparently
i mean i miss london because i love it
so much i i only envy their national
health
and it's it's ludicrous that a country
this big does not have uh anything like
that and it's
it's a major problem that has to be
resolved
but i'm not a quitter you know i i love
america and
um i've loved being here and i love the
work that i do here
and i believe very much in this country
and i don't believe in just in just
bailing out on
on something if it's not going my way i
think that's actually the time to roll
up your sleeves and
and protect the things that matter to
you
alex we've got 10 seconds left yay or
nay will there be a bill in ted 4
gosh i don't know i mean maybe if i end
up taking over keanu's role in john wick
then
you know we'll just he'll play bill and
i'll play ted and the world will get
very strange
fair enough we'll see what happens alex
thank you so much uh for taking time out
to speak with us especially on some of
the important topics
we covered take care of yourself media
you too
good to be here